[Music]
the quran
or the bible
which is the word of god for those who
are wondering we're going to answer that
very question today you came here for
debate to make that happen i have with
me ejaz ahmad before we get started
let's get to know my guest he jaws is
one of islam's leading interfaith
commentators as a religious educator
researcher and author his area of
specialty is textual criticism of the
quran and the bible it can be found
weekly on some of islam's leading shows
and is always up for a good debate
welcome to the broadcast ejoss thanks so
much for coming on great to have you
here thank you
so uh how how come you accepted the
invitation to have this uh mini debate
here on tv well the quran engages with
christians and jews and i know that you
share a jewish background and so on that
basis i think coming together and
discussing what our scriptures say
matter more to me than anything else
well excellent good good so today we're
going to confront the question the quran
or the bible which is the word of god so
my guest is ahmad a leading interfaith
commentator you know our views are very
very different i also know you love a
good debate so
let's do it you guys will both have
equal amount of time starting with three
minutes for our opening statements and
when we come to the end of your time
you'll know because you'll hear this
buzzer
all right ready to go
yep okay your time starts now three
minute opening statement
we all agree that the purpose of
scripture is twofold it informs us about
who god is and how we can be saved i
don't intend to machine gun my
interlocutor due to time constraints so
i will give a few powerful reasons why
the quran is the word of god one the
intelligibility of the creator about
himself and two god's word is sacred and
preserved in suva class that's 112 of
the quran that's one chapter for short
passages the god of the quran informs us
about who he is almost any question
about the nature of god can be answered
in it in every surah we are told about
god's mercy and grace and in the one
sewer that does not start with these
sacred words within the first five
passages we are told about god's love
and mercy intelligibility is about
saying as much as you can in as little
as you can so that everyone from the
scholar to the child can know their
creator no hellenistic philosophy
required as with hebrews 1 3 philippians
2 5-11 john 1 1 3 16 words never ever
spoken or explained by jesus himself
in both our faiths god is all-powerful
and eternal but in the bible it is god
that suffers and dies dr brown teaches
in volume four of his work that the
truth of god's message is not preserved
in any one manuscript you have to go
through all of the many mathematic texts
the dead sea scrolls the samaritan
pentateuch the syriac translations of
the bible then discover all the new
testament texts found in koine greek
latin and syriac in the hope that you
can find generalized and vague
prophecies using as he agrees ever-prone
exegetical standards that misled the
jews in jesus own time and to this very
day forget the child can any one of us
meet such an incredible standard today
no why would a loving god demand this
you will hear him say perhaps that all
you need to know is that jesus died for
your sins but does jesus make that claim
himself that's that all is that what you
need to know no both the scriptures
teach that god will preserve his word so
that we can all come to know him quran
59 and psalm 119 verse 89 but this
promise is not true of the bible to
quote dr brown editorial occupies errors
could easily creep into the text the use
of scripture was much more free-flowing
yet he concludes the multiformity of the
biblical text must be taken into account
i agree will he
god's word is sacred and if as he argues
our hasidic brothers can be misled by
their transmission and interpretation of
scripture then why should i trust
teachings which have become tradition
which may not even be authentic to begin
with in footnote 13 of volume 4 he
argues that changes by editors can
become part of the standard tradition of
sacred writings his claim not mine i
believe this is what happened with the
bible the intelligibility and sacredness
of scripture matters do they easily
matter as much to you thank you
all right thanks for your opening
statement
jesus said i am the way
the truth and the life
no one comes to the father but through
me as simple and plain as you could
possibly imagine
what's remarkable is that the quran
points people back to the torah and the
gospel the quran points people back to
the people of the book even says ask
them things so i'm so glad to be able to
answer these questions the text of the
torah and the gospel that we have today
in our bibles is the same text that
existed in the days of muhammad
when allegedly allah told him to go to
the people of the book to the torah and
to the gospel here's what we know
we have eyewitness accounts of the
crucifixion from the people who were
there recorded within a generation of it
happening we have the major roman
historian of the era tacitus referring
to jesus dying and being executed we
have eyewitness accounts preserved in
thousands and thousands of manuscripts
and yet we are supposed to believe the
quran which comes 600 years after and
denies the crucifixion we have
eyewitnesses accounts of what happened 3
000 years 2500 years before the quran
we're told no don't believe that believe
something that came later it would be
like me getting a revelation about
something that happened in muhammad's
day and i tell you believe me not the
record you have there
no book in the ancient world has been
preserved with the accuracy of the bible
nothing even close to that i'm talking
about letter for letter accuracy i'm
talking about word for word accuracy
over a period of many many centuries not
only that the bible uniquely lays out
the history of of the world it uniquely
lays out the treatment of the jewish
people scattered to all the nations
preserved in the midst of judgment and
yet regathered it lays out the messianic
prophecies how the messiah would suffer
and die and rise from the dead before
the second temple was destroyed in the
year 70 how he would be rejected by his
own people israel how he would become a
light to the gentiles and then his
people would turn it even speaks of
jerusalem being a city of controversy
for the whole world how did the biblical
authors know this they knew it because
they were inspired by god when it comes
to the preservation of the quran one
major manuscript study from uh discovery
from 1972 in yemen actually indicates
errors and differences and we do know
that the third caliph uthman gathered
together the different sources that had
different readings of the quran and
destroyed them so you were left with
only one
the bible the best preserved book in the
ancient world and it talks about our
heavenly father with all the names for
allah in the quran and tradition father
is not one of them and there's plenty of
division within the muslim world about
what to believe
all right uh very clear we've laid out
our opening statements of three minutes
now ejaz over you for your two minute
response and then i'll follow you go
ahead clock is on
thank you you said jesus said no one
came can come to me except to the father
as you know
christians call us to believe that we
don't have the very words of jesus they
fall under system of the vox are not
absolutely verbal you can read more by
daniel wallace about this secondly the
quran never says go to the bible the
bible in arabic will be much more
two terms that never use it so that
would be unequivocation you say that the
text that you have today is the same i
beg to disagree because no christian
today uses a diplomatic edition of the
greek new testament you use critical
editions which are not based on all of
the manuscript tradition as evidenced by
the ecm using the cbgm that is the
coherence-based genealogical method to
reconstruct the new testament secondly
you said that you have eyewitness
accounts of the crucifixion wrong what
you have our assumptions are the gospel
authors are eyewitnesses but this is not
the case and cannot be evidenced
remember church tradition does not mean
that your tradition is true you will
need to validate and very fight in the
same way that you disagree with what the
rabbis say about their own traditions in
the talmud uh you mentioned that tacitus
was a witness correction tacitus was not
a witness he's writing after the year
115 or 117 after empire tradition had
died and he actually called jesus christ
us not christ us he got that major
detail wrong his very name secondly he
never mentions the crucifixion he says
in latin the most severe punishment so
there is no need to equivocate you we
need to be specific with the claims that
we make you say that the quran comes 600
years after i beg to disagree god can
reveal revelation at any time in history
just as he accounted for the genesis
accounts many thousands of years after
but moses peace be upon him uh you also
mentioned that let me see here the
messianic prophecies as i said these
cannot be qualified this is based on a
poor understanding of jewish uh
exegetical standards as yourself claim
had led the jews to be misled about who
the messiah is lastly codex does not
actually matter because it is not used
as an archetype for the quran and we
know that has lapses as evidenced by dr
alba fidelity and her great work on it
lastly uthman burned the quranic
manuscripts which were different and
incorrectly written with the incorrect
watson yugo and papyri not parchment
thank you
right so number one you admit that there
are errors or discrepancies in the quran
they've just been suppressed number two
we have a wealth of evidence and there's
something called textual criticism where
you sift through it to come up with the
most accurate reading and you can have
hebrew manuscripts from 1 000 years
after jesus that are in letter for
letter agreement with manuscripts from
100 years before jesus this is a simple
fact i didn't say that tacitus was an
eyewitness but rather historian as for
the disciples being eyewitnesses richard
balcom's written an excellent book on
eyewitnesses of jesus where he gives
clear evidence i also said that tacit
said that jesus was executed i did make
that correction as i was saying it as
for your misrepresentation of what i
wrote my own books no it is with doing
solid biblical exegesis that you see the
prophecies are what they are as for the
idea that we don't have the words of
jesus of course we have the words of
jesus when he quotes things where does
it say that those are not his actual
words you may have a scholar debating
various things there but of course they
are presented as the words of jesus we
have every reason to believe them what's
so remarkable is that even within islam
you have these massive divisions between
sunni and shia if things were presented
so clearly and beautifully and
wonderfully you'd think that there'd
just be everybody believing the same
thing what's also remarkable with the
emphasis on allahim
the fact is that you can work your
hardest you can do your very very best
you can follow all the five pillars of
islam and you still do not have
assurance that when you die you go to
paradise in fact you've got to pray in a
certain order and live a certain way
because at best you are a servant of
allah whereas the bible tells us how you
can have a personal relationship with
god as for jesus not saying he was dying
for our sins at the last supper he said
this is my body which is given for you
he also said that his life was a ransom
for many and he pointed to isaiah 53
which tells us that he bore our sins the
bible again far and away the best
preserved book in the ancient world and
when muhammad received his revelation it
was 600 years after the time of jesus
all right it's about to get a little bit
more interesting we're going to do rapid
fire so it's one minute back and forth
three times then 30 seconds back and
forth three stones starting as always
with my esteemed guest ejad over to you
so no i don't admit i was in the quran
we can see that there are changes in the
manuscript tradition otherwise known as
lapses calamity textual critics do not
consider lapses calamity which is
transcriptional errors i was by the eye
parablepsis as being actual errors
errors would be exchanged the text like
an ammunition with what we have of the
greek industry and secondly you say we
can know what the manuscript saved
because of textual criticism this is
actually incorrect if you bother to read
the ubs third greek new testament that
actually gives a reason to know to each
variant units in the new testament only
nine percent of either 8.9 of all the
variant units chosen are they certain
about 90 plus percent they have doubt so
if your textual or your own textual
scholars can doubt what the bible says
that's on you not on me broken does not
prove that these are actually actually
eyewitnesses and nothing actually
demonstrates that in his work i have
read it in detail so the question comes
to you how do you know that these are
the words of jesus other than an
assumption without evidence can you
please give one basis of textual
evidence within the first century to
confirm this thank you
and point to fact you have no clue if
muhammad made up every word or someone
gave it to him in other words you can't
prove what you believe that you just
believe it most of the textual areas
that that you pointed to that's the same
thing we have in scrabble transmission
of biblical documents and scholars can
point that out and point in fact there
is not one major doctrine that is in
question
whatsoever in terms of what the bible
teaches based on the various textual
readings as as for eyewitness accounts
we didn't have cameras back then we
didn't have videotape running but
according to the best evidence these are
eyewitness accounts and according to
what we've seen in the unfolding of
history of jesus backing his word then
we see that he continues to speak he
continues to act but ultimately there is
a taking something by faith you taking
the quran being inspired me taking the
bible being inspired but you know surah
29 46 believe in that which was sent
down to us also i'm telling you what was
sent down to us it's found in the bible
which has been wonderfully accurately
preserved
all right so thank you for your response
dr bronn i beg to differ as uh
dr david alan black points out in his
book on an introduction to actual
criticism he says that there are many
actually important textual variants
which do affect doctrine specifically he
points out of uh the variants where
jesus is speaking to nicodemus and says
that he's in both heaven and earth that
is a variant there secondly the use of
the word monogenes for example is
another variant does it mean begotten or
uniquely created these are terms which
have led people into errors and as you
would know a baker's encyclopedia and
other sources basically say that this
tomb was misused by jerome when
translated from unicus into unigenitus
in the new testament so i do beg to
differ on the textual variants lastly
you mentioned in your book that there
were important distinctions and variants
between the two forms of the texture of
the first ten commandments your claim
not mine lastly the quran does not say
your book it says what allah has
revealed uh in quran 2 4
51 2. so quran 2 5 46 to 47 and point in
point of fact the torah and the gospel
that are referenced were the only ones
that existed in other words there was
not a different text at that time when
allah allegedly told muhammad about the
torah in the gospel it's what we have as
the torah and the gospel it was not
subsequently changed and again why on
earth would i believe someone 600 years
later denying denying the crucifixion of
the messiah when people who were there
or people at the very least within a
generation we have manuscripts going
back that far attest to what had
happened and it's not a it's not an
account that you would come up with
because of the ignominy of crucifixion
when it comes to david allen black
you'll also know that he's absolutely
confident in the text of scriptureness
has been involved in bible translation
because he knows we have god's word and
the one disputed text in john 3 about
son of man which is in heaven has almost
universally said no this is a later
edition you're giving a misleading
impression about textual science and
again uthman takes the many variants and
even trying to find who said what do we
even have this in the quran and destroys
the other that's why you have more
uniformity the others were destroyed
okay to respond to that quickly that
would actually be incorrect we have the
killer at and as dr uh cook actually
mentions in his 2004 paper we know that
they come from one source earlier you
mentioned how can we know using the
science of somatics something that
cannot be done with the new testament
because we don't have any archetypal
text i will also continue here you said
i must misrepresented dr david alan
black actually i'm not he himself says
it's a major doctrinal variant not me
his words i would also add here no you
cannot know what jesus said and that you
are assumed that they are eyewitnesses
it's not proof that they are
eyewitnesses to claim that it was
written within the same generation again
as a supposition we have no new
testament texts within the first century
ce and according to uh at least
papyrologists when we did the gospel
sorry billions of billiographers when we
did the gospels bibliography the uh
terminus antique women and terminus
program that unit of time actually spans
between 100 150 years so we may not have
even a single new testament document
within the second century ce please
answer these questions i'd appreciate it
in point of fact we have manuscript
evidence even from within the first
century the second thing is in terms of
comparing to other evidence it's
remarkably early when you look at all
the other evidence when you look at
various historical documents and famous
poetry it's remarkable how many
witnesses we have you're turning the
thing exactly upside down it's for david
allen black again look to where he says
that there's major dispute we don't know
what this doctrine says no there's
agreement on what the doctrine actually
is in the text in point of fact as i've
said again the quran points to torah and
gospel we know what torah and gospel
were in muhammad's day we know where he
got things wrong based on information he
had that he misunderstood we know where
the confusions come in the quran where
biblical figures are misunderstood and
things like that we know all of that go
back to the eyewitnesses and you say how
do we know they're eyewitnesses because
their disciples and their followers
repeated it and repeated it and we have
a strong and clear tradition going right
back to the cross going right back to
jesus
so we actually have no evidence like i
said that this is eyewitness to
eyewitness transmission again this is
church tradition being read back into
history i want evidence not assumptions
last year you're equivocating what the
quran says it never says go to the torah
and the gospel specifically as you know
in your own book you testify there is no
one there attached to a tradition and
secondly what christians considered the
the juan galleon the good news to be
differed across the empire especially
when we had more apocryphal works being
read in egypt than anywhere else at the
same time as the prophet peace be upon
him
right again when the torah and gospel
are pointed to within the quran for
alleged validation
and we are told go to them because they
prophesy of muhammad what torah and
gospel existed in muhammad's day the
same torah and gospel we have that
touring gospel does not at any point
ever mention muhammad hint and muhammad
except to warn about false prophets who
will lead the word astray quran points
to torah and gospel torah and gospel do
not point to muhammad fact
not fact because again i said you're
equivocating another says your gospel
doctrine if you were a christian living
in egypt at that time you would be
reading the non-appropriate you would be
reading the apocryphal works another
canonical gospels again i would suggest
that you look at the manuscript record
lastly you claim that it was first
century manuscript evidence for the
crucifixion and for eyewitness testimony
dr brown what is that evidence because
no new testament textual critic in any
way in the world claims that you have
that early evidence it's either second
or third century c to start with yeah
i'm not equivocating you are putting
words in my mouth there are new
testament manuscripts and a single
piracy in there that have been dated
within the first century i did not say
that it was specifically about the
crucifixion secondly you know islamic
apologists are constantly quoting the
bible we have and alleging that it
points to muhammad and then saying it's
not the real bible which is it either we
have the real bible that allegedly
points to muhammad but in fact it
doesn't or we don't have the real bible
you can't have it both ways it's
double-minded to argue that
so it doesn't matter what other muslim
apologists say what matters is what i
see so if you want to use the force
dichotomy here or you prefer their
statements online that will be incorrect
secondly like i said we have nothing
dated to within 100 years of jesus that
can be said to be accurately textual
critically manuscript twice dated to
within a hundred years of his time the
earliest one is possibly p52 but the
paleographic date range extends into the
third century ce based on the comparanda
provided by ch roberts and dr brent
nonprofit so friends any of you can
check earliest new testament manuscripts
get online and search for yourself again
when you have 5 000 manuscripts within
the first centuries no ancient document
in the world has been preserved like
that and then here's what you have you
have the eyewitnesses who are willing to
die for their faith and their disciples
writing in the generation immediately
thereafter you have a transmission which
is second to none it points us back to
jesus who said he is the way the truth
and the life
all right is that the uh we are done we
are almost over but we each get a final
word uh he just i appreciate your
preparation and and all the data that
you're giving obviously we have strong
differences here but you get your last
minute then i get mine go ahead so thank
you uh uh doctor uh i do appreciate dr
brown your time here with me i do look
forward to your be you it'll be it's a
doc brother zachary who's seen in london
i know we all look forward to that with
a great deal so again i i think the
conversation today was actually pleasant
i did enjoy it but again there is no
only testament manuscript
within at least a century of christ
jesus you can look up on the intf
website you can consult the logos new
testament manuscript explorer in fact i
have dr david alan black's book here and
i have my critical edition of the new
testament here so exactly i do know
specifically when the gospel is related
to and how we arrive at those dates i
would end by saying this if the
manuscript episode evidence was that
easy to cite then dr brown should have
been able to cite at least one
manuscript but he couldn't he would have
provided evidence that there were
eyewitness testimony instead he has to
support and be back into history when
theoretically these traditions can be
dated the fact is there is no manuscript
evidence indicates now this is
eyewitness testimony thank you
again just because ejaz did not like
this highly respected book by richard
balcom on eyewitnesses of jesus i would
encourage you to read it and check it
out for yourself
the second thing once again is do not be
confused
look at the data of ancient books and
how they are preserved nothing compares
with the preservation of scripture and
then the most important thing of all and
go ahead check out manuscripts check all
the evidence please do that and then
compare that with the textual evidence
for the quran you will be staggered by
the difference remember the quran points
us back to the scriptures and the
scriptures point us to jesus if you want
to know the heavenly father if you want
to be saved and come into right
relationship with god not by working
harder and harder but always falling
short if you want to understand what
real mercy and grace are they come to
one place revealed by god through jesus
in the bible the one and only word of
god
all right okay that was wonderful
friends uh thanks so much e jaws really
appreciate you coming on thoroughly
enjoyed doing so i hope you enjoyed it
as well
i did thank you very much dr brown i
look forward to engaging you again yes
thank you